simple as it is in premise
Counter-Strike might actually be the
most complex FPS
ever created with unique spray patterns
batshit crazy utility lineups and a
full-scale in-game economy improving
your gameplay can be a pretty daunting
experience but there is one aspect of
the game that you must at the very least
become competent at if you want to
actually as they say
get good it's something that the average
player might not bother practicing but
when used correctly it can absolutely
take your game to the next level twist
talk about his impact this would be some
time to find out the rat in the hole do
you consider that he did it and he slaps
him down
[Applause]
these bucks
and the dying stages of Regulation as
they're gone 15. I am of course talking
about that mystical ethereal
all-encompassing construct known as
movement and look at this what on Earth
Nifty wow movement boys
from a two versus four but he's gonna
hold the plan that gives Kyo a chance
and he makes it work perfectly has done
a tremendous excuse me job of doing
something
bunny hopping is one of those things
that can provide a massive advantage in
certain situations and many of the
world's best players know how to use it
to maximize their movement across the
map but what exactly is bee hopping and
how important is it for the average
player well lucky for you today we're
gonna find out
[Applause]
okay so before we start talking about
them crispy hops I must ask that you
like the channel nope like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications also be sure to check out
our brand new line of merch we got
t-shirts screws hoodies and I can
honestly say buy us aside that aside
from being very well made the thing I
really like about this clothing is that
it fits me like a glove I know a lot of
y'all are like five nine or at least act
like it in the comments but I'm almost
six five and it's genuinely very hard
for me to find Long clothing so this
stuff actually fits me like a glove okay
so even though bunny hopping or bee
hopping for short has actually been a
crucial aspect of counter-strike's
gameplay for years Gamers were messing
around with it years before
Counter-Strike even existed shortly
after a quake released back in 1996
players realized that by continually
jumping in a consistent Rhythm they
could actually move much faster than if
they had just run in a straight line in
fact running forward was just about the
slowest way you could get around in the
original Quake even strafing from side
to side around corners was quicker but
when combining strafing with jumping
players were able to reach the game's
maximum movement threshold because no
velocity was lost while your character
was Airborne you'd only lose speed when
you touched the ground without
continuing your air strafe at the time
this technique was given the name strafe
jumping and although it wasn't actually
very common within the multiplayer
Community it was a necessity for the
game's speedrunning Community
unfortunately quake's developer in
software weren't really thrilled that
fans were finding ways to exploit the
game's movement infrastructures and
tried removing it from future titles but
in 1998 valve released one of the most
influenced potential FPS games ever
Half-Life Half-Life was built on a
modded version of the original Quake
engine called gold source and while ID
software was trying their absolute
darndest to remove movement exploits
from their game valve didn't really seem
to mind big surprise soon players began
speed running Half-Life and perfecting
their strafe jumping mechanics while
pushing to improve their times but
Half-Life also introduced a new type of
movement wall strafing by pushing your
character into walls at specific angles
you were able to gain additional speed
so speedrunners made use of all these
mechanics to complete each and every
level as quickly as possible before we
move on it should be noted that
speedrunners such as these used the
scroll wheel to jump and since then
pretty much every valve title has
benefited from this keybind in fact it's
become the sort of calling card of
counter-strike's movement community at
large by tying one's jump bind to each
and every Notch of the scroll wheel
spinning a set wheel all but guarantees
that you won't miss the timing on a
particular hop anyway half-life's
modding Community was pretty extensive
and in 1999 it birthed the ever-goted
half-life Counter-Strike due to the
popularity of the mod valve approached
the creators just a year later and
purchased the intellectual property
publishing the polished version of the
game in September of the year 2000 but
bunny hopping and Counter-Strike was
unlike anything that came before it
because while Half-Life speedrunners had
been using the technique to best their
own times in single player runs CS
offered a multiplayer game mode which
eventually spawned an even larger Pro
scene
foreign
the benefits of bunny hopping in a
competitive environment were of course
self-explanatory they made you a harder
Target to hit since it forced enemies to
sort of track your sporadic movement but
it also helped players learn skill jumps
and once modders began creating KZ and
b-hop and even surf Maps practicing
movement became pretty routine I think
Casey in 1.6 is like the the best moment
in any game it's uh very natural and
it's very very silly bunny hopping in
particular became even more popular with
the release of Counter-Strike Source but
this was in large part thanks to one
player and if you know anything at all
about bunny hopping then you know who it
is I'm talking about but for all the
sewers out there pun very much intended
it is time to discuss the goat that is
I can hear the music now
[Music]
foon's too much for z-block was a
masterpiece it was the perfect Montage
of movement frags and of course BM that
single 10 minute video is a seminal
entry in the history of Counter-Strike
related media and mythology and it
turned him into a literal Legend but
Foon was so good at bee hopping that
some players actually questioned whether
he was legit had he really mastered the
game's movement or was he creating these
clips with the use of automated scripts
if you're asking me if I think he was
legit the answer is yes that being said
people just forget that like before some
of the restrictions on movement and
stuff like that it's not easy but just
that it was very doable there were a lot
of movement things in stores that were
very forgiving and by no means was it
easy and I could not do it like when I
had to play against them there were
times where I straight up would not
leave CT spawn on nuke like I would just
wait for him because I knew he'd try it
every round like he knew like so in a
way it was kind of like bad to have him
on your team because he was either
getting you know these crazy ridiculous
kills or he's an absolute liability now
from what Flom told me Foon did actually
attend some small lands where he was
able to Showcase his clean hops
Unfortunately they weren't exactly
recorded for posterity only a handful of
people got to witness Foon and his
Shenanigans in the flesh and although he
sort of intentionally faded away Into
Obscurity there's almost no overstating
the foundational role that this
mysterious man played in both pioneering
and popularizing but bunny hopping as a
whole really I think Foon really pushed
the boundaries and like showed people
like what was possible with movement
right it's obviously not something
that's always tangible in like
competitive games but he did kind of
pave this past for all these different
movement players in CS now which is
honestly I think very enjoyable to watch
a lot of his Ode to people like phone
who uh really kind of opened the gates
for having movement be this thing that
you can pursue and had that be like that
kind of skill that you can kind of
prioritize more so than even your aim
and your uh game sets and everything
else so I think it's really cool by the
time CS Go released in 2012 pretty much
anyone who took Counter-Strike seriously
was at the very least aware of their
movement and although you definitely
don't see Pro players bunny hopping
around the map in every Pro match
hitting the right hop at the right time
can absolutely make a difference in even
the most basic of gunfights potentially
a second critical error in the opening
six rounds quick movements just trying
to dodge dive okay
the indirect kind of benefit of knowing
how to Bunny Hop and having good
movement will just improve your overall
prowess in the game mechanically when it
comes to using your movement to win aim
duels or get to places faster or to make
little little skill jumps that are in
the game in CS go even a well-timed surf
can give way to an absolutely decadent
dumpstering
oh
10 hundred points to Gryffindor of
course most of us aren't named zyrule
but learning to finesse one's movement
can absolutely Elevate even a gold Nova
players game
and luckily there are no shortage of
resources to learn how to do it nowadays
there is a near endless number of
community servers one can connect to and
workshop Maps one can download in order
to master one's movement now a lot of
people myself included play these Maps
because they're fun and relaxing but the
skills that can be refined while playing
them can eventually translate into real
matches regardless of what rank you are
I mean it wasn't really like a thing
like I was like consciously trying to
improve it was just the thing that I I
found fun and it was another thing that
I could improve on right it wasn't like
I was thinking like oh if I can learn
how to you know do serve Kitsune in like
a minute then I can become uh you know
rank G on esca or something you just see
yourself improve in certain aspects of
the game and movement is just a big part
of that uh you can just see yourself you
can tell when a player has good movement
when a player has bad movement and CS go
very easily so if you're a CS player and
you are not at the very least aware as
to how hopping works then honestly
you're kind of trolling if you're asking
yourself how do I go about learning how
it works fortunately I forced Colton to
learn how it works so he could explain
it to you and now the guy who actually
knows what he's talking about
you want me to what
so let me get this straight you call me
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about then write a bunch of
scripts about Counter-Strike and
valorant and now you want me to teach
people how to Bunny Hop I thought this
was a tech show okay in Counter-Strike
when running in a straight line with
your knife out your character's Max
velocity is 250 units per second a
measurement of speed that's almost as
meaningless as whatever Americans are
using the goal of executing the clean
Bunny Hop is to surpass that velocity so
let's break down the tech one input at a
time first of all you probably want to
bind your jump to your scroll wheel like
the guy who should actually be
explaining this Dimitri mentioned
earlier it will make it much harder to
miss your jump timing to start the Bunny
Hop press your W key or S key depending
on which direction you want to go once
you start jumping release the key and
use both A and D in order to gain
velocity you can also b-hop from side to
side by starting with a or D and then
strafing with w and S just remember to
keep moving your mouse in rhythm with
your b-hops otherwise you'll slow down
but don't be discouraged urge if you
can't nail it immediately it can take a
while to learn how to execute clean bee
hops or an eternity in fact if like me
you don't play the game but your efforts
won't go unrewarded because nothing
feels better than hitting that perfect
sh movement and that was the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
plenty of modern titles use some sort of
movement mechanics but before we wrap
things up we gotta talk about valorant I
know I'm sorry but like most things in
valorant bunny hopping is a hell of a
lot easier than it is in CS go
mostly because it doesn't really exist
in valorant bunny hopping is is close to
useless
um because you can't actually get any
sort of velocity boost you can't get
from point A to point B Faster by bunny
hopping if anything if you mess up
you're probably going to end up there
slower so I really don't like how the
skill ceiling for movement in Valor is
so low it's like super duper low it's it
feels really
um just like really static you know
um there's a whole lot of flexibility
with the movement what Riot did was
essentially give players the illusion of
being able to bunny hop in the interest
of making the game more accessible and
appealing to a casual player base since
there are agents who have their own
dedicated movement abilities it was
probably a good decision from Riot we've
already seen players push the boundaries
of what's possible for these agents and
it is made from some pretty insane plays
so far oh here he goes and it's a little
bit of what we saw right The Flash the
gravity well just like what we saw in
round one and sick for in the first
round it was Dapper this round it was
sick who tastes a little bit of that
bunny bunny action bunny hopping has
come a long way since the early days of
quake and Half-Life and even CS
and yet in other ways it's sort of
stayed exactly the same there's a good
chance that the FPS game that you play
today has some sort of bee hopping
mechanic built into it so hopefully
after today some of you will consider
putting a little bit of extra time into
practicing your movement rather than
just your aim it might be more useful
for some Shooters than others but I
think we can all agree that mastering
one's movement
it's just straight up fun probably not
do you watch peaky blinders it's some
English like a very English uh TV show
about
um Birmingham in the 1920s and 30s if
you don't watch the show it's not going
to mean as much to you but Danny does
the most unbelievable impression we
never would let him get away with this
in France never in France
oh sorry there oh sorry bud